joining me today is a trial lawyer
focusing on civil criminal and
constitutional law and according to his
Twitter bio he's America's most
successful political gambler Robert
Barnes welcome to the Rubin report happy
to be here I am glad to have you here
because you sir are smack dab in the
middle of a million things that I'm
thinking about all the time so I'm glad
we're doing this before we do anything
related to civil criminal constitutional
or any other kind of law political
gambler what are we talking about there
I know what we're talking about but tell
the people sure I started doing when I
was really young so the I used to bet
friends and other people with elections
and then started doing it became sort of
legal loosely in 2004 so I started
betting on presidential elections and
was sort of a side hobby until the Trump
election and Trump I thought this was a
very money-making opportunity the
British betting markets are now much
bigger than they ever used to be so I
could bet as much money as I possibly
could and in and basically dug in much
deeper than I had before so I've sort of
been around politics but hadn't done in
deep for maybe you know 20 years or so I
mean I've been very active but then it
become inactive it becomes skeptical the
political process and decided well I
should really dig in and as part of this
I discovered this whole emerging
movement in a cross-section of areas and
what was happening ideologically so I
became involved for other political and
legal reasons along the way it was sorta
like a scott adams win big league where
you get the six there somewhere exactly
there you go exactly where you get like
six degrees of separation you're trying
to learn this you end up learning four
or five other things in the process and
so I went to the Republican National
Convention the Democratic National
Convention traveled across the country
talked to tons of people dug into what
was happening the social media space the
reddit space the Twitter space I didn't
know what Twitter was until then really
I knew but some Earth Day it was a
happier time exactly it was and from
YouTube was still YouTube you know who
wasn't censor to so the I was uh you
know involved and invested in it went
over to the UK placed a lot of big bets
they thought I was nuts when I was doing
it they're like how Trump's not gonna
get elected that was the sort of
consensus so much so that one of the big
books
paddy power actually was paying out
Hillary Clinton bats before the election
Jesus so if you'd bet on Hillary Clinton
with Paddy Power they acted like you had
already won and paid you out are they
still in business they are so business
though they took a huge hit on the
election after they'd taken a big hit on
brexit which I've been on before that
and then after that had bet on various
European elections so it was just
understanding how the electorate works
I'm a sports bettor as well and being
able to predict and forecast elections
was fun and it was a way to just make
extra money and in the process ended up
having this whole life experience that
was fun and entertaining and very
profitable can I ask you what kind of
profits we're talking about how about
half a million dollars very nice if I
could admit if I could have bet more I
would have bet more yeah there was only
limits as an American you only have
access to the individual betting shops
you can't get onto the bet fair and the
bet trade and markets if I could I could
have made seven figures where they use
it would have been nice jeez all right
well there's a lot to talk about there
but but I really want to focus on some
of the legal stuff because we chatted a
little bit in the greenroom I'm starting
to think as much as much I obviously am
a free speech guy and we're going to
talk all about the First Amendment all
sorts of things that the way the world
is going right now with the platforms
and with the trolls and with the
anonymous accounts and with the targeted
harassment and with the way that we see
media members attacking kids which
you're very intimately involved with and
a whole bunch of others have I'm
starting to think we really need some
legal answers to some of these problems
which is really against my default
position as a person in terms of speech
and that's exactly why I wanted to have
you here so before we get to all that
just tell me a little bit about your
legal history when did you even get
interested in law and what sort of made
you say alright I'm gonna be a lawyer
lawyers are that well like I'm gonna be
one exactly well you know I've always
liked underdog representation and that's
sort of what my legal practice is and
that goes back home as a kid my favorite
TV show is the equalizer as always the
odds and and to represent people against
even if I'm representing someone that's
famous are well-known they're stacked up
against someone that has more
institutional power wealth or the US
government behind it and so as a kid I
like shows like Matlock and Perry Mason
and that was part of it and and you
you'd see lawyers as being integral to
the process of making meaningful change
and particularly to stand up for people
who couldn't stand up for themselves and
use our legal system and legal rights to
accomplish achieve those objectives and
so that's why the law always appealed to
me it didn't appeal to me from a
money-making perspective though I've
been very you know had been lucky in
that regard it appealed to me and then
appeared to appeal to me on a status
basis it appealed to me is I can make a
difference for little people people like
my father who spoke out his whole life
and theirs in Austin was punished for it
and the there's the old biblical proverb
that says the sins of the father will be
visited on the son I always say well the
sins against the father are long
remembered by the son and so he was
mistreated and now treated because he
stood up not for himself but for other
people in a wide range of environments
and I just wanted to equalize the
playing field if I could and was he a
lawyer also no he wasn't he was he was
an accountant but it wasn't a certified
public accountant so the he went through
all the craziness that it was my first
experience with the credentialing
Society here my father was a very
skilled and gifted accountant but
because he wasn't a certified public
accountant he'd grown up in an era where
that wasn't necessary he couldn't get
the kind of jobs that other people could
do and so he was often both
overqualified at under qualified for
employment and then he had a habit of
standing up for people who are being
maltreated or mistreated in his work
environment or other environment which
led to him he end up being a newspaper
delivery guy so when I was a little kid
we he was delivering newspapers throwing
him outside the other door we did a
morning around and afternoon around and
then he end up doing inventory work so
he just picked up whatever blue-collar
work he could so even though his
education and his intellectual
capabilities far exceeded what he could
get economically it was a product or a
side effect of the credentialing Society
and the ability of more powerful people
to take advantage and misuse and abuse
that power against less powerful people
like himself Wow
so alright so let's flash forward a
little bit to what was maybe one or two
of the cases that kind of got you got
you sort of on the map so that now
you've become one of the sort of I think
one of the central legal figures in the
the free speech battle so I started out
doing all kinds of free speech
representation represented victims of
domestic violence was suing big banks
before anybody was suing big banks and
subprime lending was I'd clerked for a
Native American tribe I'd clerk for a
big corporate law firm I'd clerked for a
street lawyer always say if anybody
wants to learn legal education just read
all john grisham's
you'll get a good sense about the legal
practice really works and worked for a
big high-profile plaintiff's lawyer and
finally got to a space where I could do
the kind of cases I wanted to do and I
liked First Amendment cases and that
happened to parallel to areas of law one
was civil where I was representing Ralph
Nader he went on TV and said look I'm
getting bombarded I have no lawyers left
to help me if somebody can please reach
out I was like sure I'll take the case
so there was I remember we did the case
in Arizona was me Ralph Nader and like
12 lawyers kept coming in I kept
wondering when the door was good another
lawyer came another you had the
Democratic Party Republican Party both
aligned to prevent his access to the
ballot deny people the right to
circulate petitions for the cause or
candidate of their choice and so I took
that case and it took four years a lot
of litigation a lot of fighting but
ultimately we got one of the most
important precedents in the country out
of the Ninth Circuit Court of Appeals
it's now one of the most cited cases in
the country that protects the right to
circulate petitions the rights of speech
in the context of elections the right to
choose who you want on the ballot the
right of third parties and independent
candidates to access the ballot in a
weird way though even though just by the
fact that it took four years isn't that
part of the problem right there cuz yes
four years later it's like he doesn't
necessarily have the energy to run again
or her sight movement kind of moves on
to something else etcetera it was like
the beginning of law fair of its own
time politically motivated ideological
law fair to exclude independent and
dissident voices from being able to
meaningfully participate in the
political process and the main goal and
objective is to silence the audience to
not allow the audience to hear or choose
or participate in the way they want to
choose they don't get to choose their
news they don't get to choose their
views that's what the censorship
campaigns were about and that crossed
over into representing people who are
accused of being tax protesters and
these were people had very distinct
political views about the way the tax
laws were operating they were mostly
upfront about it with the IRS I mean how
many people you know write letters
saying I'm not gonna pay taxes and
here's why mostly these were
libertarians basically right it's never
somebody that hates the tax system
because they want to be taxed more right
that's never happened precisely and it's
people being open and honest about
they're not trying to cheat anybody that
I'm trying to defraud anybody and you
have Supreme Court it said 20 years ago
in a case called cheek versus the United
States they were not supposed to put
people in prison for having different
beliefs about the tax laws especially
given this is a country that was founded
on people who had very unique beliefs
about the tax
so I end up representing Wesley Snipes
in that context I'd also represented him
previously when he'd been falsely
accused of parenting a child in New York
where they were abusing the family court
system to invade his privacy to lie and
libel him and basically because of his
celebrity used his celebrity to make
themselves notorious so we brought a
unique civil rights case and that
context had one got them to fold and
capitulate he hired me then to represent
him in the criminal case on a whole
bunch of tax charges and it of acquitted
of all the felony fraud conspiracy
charges and even half the misdemeanor
charges on cases like that I'm always
curious when it's a high-profile rich
celebrity and it's tax related I always
think it's like these people a guy like
Wesley Snipes movie star you know he's
worth millions and millions of dollars
the idea that he would and I don't know
the specifics so please correct me if
I'm wrong but the idea that he would
know every specific thing that his
accountant was doing all the time seems
crazy to me like he's running a business
where he's mostly probably focused on
acting and traveling and everything else
and it's like the idea that unless he
instructed the guy to do something
illegal that you'd end up in jail
because of something like that seems
pretty bananas to me completely because
what happened with him is he had one
accountant advisor that he started to
distrust so I think this guy's up to
something on on real estate deals and
other deals it turned out he was
completely right he was trying to tell
the New York authorities four years
before the guy end up getting busted and
he had this guy was involved with Tom
Brokaw he was representing a whole
roster of high-profile celebrities
turned out he was embezzling from them
and mass he had abandoned his wife for a
stripper long story so the this kind of
going to jail for a long time but but
Snipes was like hey there's a problem
here nobody would listen and that led
him to turn to other professionals and
they said you know what if you have any
questions we'll go right to the
government and get your answers he was
like well that's got to be no problem
they're gonna talk to the government
they'll figure out what it is no way
that's how this unfolded that's how this
whole thing unfolded it was in fact they
even tried to delete and destroy all of
his letters and correspondence in
communications and luckily they were he
had separately backed them up if he
hadn't we wouldn't have been able to
prove how much he had communicated
directly to them he even asked to be
audited he said come in and audit me and
then come back and tell me what is it I
owe and why it is I owe it and how does
the legal system work and this is
someone rooted in the
frickin American and Native American
tradition who has a long history the law
is not being applied the way they're
supposed to be on the books so the idea
that maybe the law is not being applied
the way it's supposed to be wasn't
foreign to him Native American tribes
whose tribal agreements are still not
being enforced you have African
Americans between 1865 and 1955 of the
United States like his parents like his
grandparents who said the law in the
book said they had the right to
participate in the political process the
right to be on the jury the right to run
for office and yet that wasn't happening
in reality so the idea that there was
some mismatch here made sense to him and
he just wanted he's a well school right
to the government and I'm Wesley Snipes
I have a little bit of attention don't
forget sir my questions at least and
then everything will get resolved that's
why the jury was shocked by the case
this was a very conservative jury the
lead jury foreman was a guy who had been
a long time corrections officer in
upstate New York
they deliberately manipulated the jury
pool they picked it was literally an
all-white jury pool so there was a joke
that it was as the only thing more white
than the snowfall from the Green Bay
Packer in New York the day before was
the very pool in this nice case but nine
of the 12 jurors who are honest and got
onto the jury said they didn't think he
should be convicted of anything there
are three jurors who were holdouts who
said we want to convict him of things
and we came in with the admitted they
came in with a bias before they became
part of the jury so on the misdemeanors
they did a split verdict they said well
we'll convict him on these three
misdemeanors even though we don't think
he's guilty of him because that will be
no problem they didn't know there'd be a
wacky sentence because there was shocked
at the outcome of the case so how much
of law is just that just the public
attention stuff manipulating the media I
don't have to name I could probably name
a zillion lawyers that seem like they're
far more interested in Fame for
themselves than doing the right thing
and just managing optics rather than
getting to just what is right precisely
that's what it often is I mean you're
seeing it now in the Roger stone case
where there's an obsession with
silencing it and all the people on the
media on the left that talked about free
speech and talk about the ability to
protect yourself and our criminal
justice system has problems are suddenly
muted when here is you have a judge
spending all this time saying maybe we
shouldn't allow him to publish a book
how has that become part of American
criminal justice process so the
effectively at often is defending
person in the court of public opinion
because often what the government is
doing is using people as sin goats using
people as sacrificial lambs using people
to coerce public opinion often not
really rooted in the facts of a case not
really rooted in the law of the case
targeting people solely because of their
celebrity or their fame and then you
have lawyers who often look at a case
and they don't look at the case about
how do I win the case they look at how
do I get the most press coverage how do
I get the most media coverage and they
often deserve their clients in that
context so it's critically important
especially in high-profile cases to put
the client first and to manage the court
of public opinion at the same time yeah
and that cannot be easy especially in a
day of social media and look at the fact
you're here talking so it's not like
you're not like a totally private person
no and yet you want to do what's right
by your clients and exactly so like in
Snipes case the I think the odds going
back to huh it wasn't up to the odds of
he was convicted of the top felony fraud
counts was 8 to 1 so there was a day
said there was only about a 10 11
percent chance of him being acquitted
you had see you know people on CNN
saying that he had no chance to win some
are still prominent legal commentary now
how do we always have legal comment
commentary people on CNN often but all
the cable networks who get everything
wrong and they keep bringing them back
it's like their political what precisely
and these are people that have mostly
never practiced law never tried a case
never dealt with a real case and and
it's amazing they'll just they're there
they have a law degree but they often
don't have any legal experience and
they're really there for for political
purposes they know if they say the right
thing that their media boss doesn't want
them to say they'll get rewarded even if
what they're saying is complete and
utter nonsense yeah so one of the things
that I've been saying over the last
couple years and and you know I'm a free
speech guy is that right now I'm more
concerned that we're silencing ourselves
then the government is coming for our
speech at this very moment now of course
I understand the government can always
come for our speech and there are many
ways that you're laying out right there
that they can through going through the
IRS or whatever else but I'm more
concerned right now about sort of the
mob mentality the way we're weaponizing
the
and social media and the rest of it so
let's just start with the big question
right now social media are these
publishers or platforms right now
Twitter Facebook YouTube and can you
explain the difference between the
absolutely so all of these big tech
platforms originally we're able to
obtain their monopoly status two ways
first they got Congress to pass special
immunity laws loosely called section 230
the particular section of the laws that
applies that says we're going to presume
that everything you do is as a platform
and not as a publisher and consequently
you'll be immune from any lawsuit as a
publisher as long as you are acting as a
platform so meaning that you're just the
you're just the space so to speak people
can put all kinds of crap up on there
you can decide what you take down or
leave up but you're not endorsing it
exactly you're just a public venue your
your the the venue where they're coming
to organize the Republican Party on the
election night right you're the
restaurant you're the there you're the
convention center that's all you are and
then that was even additionally
privately promised by people like Jack
at Twitter who said I'll be the free
speech wing of the free speech party so
he induces people to participate induces
people to become part of Twitter and to
give them in a competitive economic edge
against their then competitors on the
grounds that hey look one the law only
applies if were a platform not a
publisher secondly we are promising you
we will protect your free speech rights
in your free speech liberties now it's
important in that context free speech
means the right to not be stopped for
your speech their right not to be
harassed for your speech the right not
to be censored for your speech it's both
that's why my style for a free speech is
not just the right of expression it
means I have a rights that someone can't
target me because of my expression and
use elicit mechanisms they can question
my ideas they can attack my ideas if I'm
a public figure they have limited space
in which they can talk about me as a
person but what they can't do is invade
my privacy what they can't do is follow
me down the street what they can't do is
put a billboard outside my home these
are things they can't do so is that a to
me that's a really fascinating change on
the way things have happened because if
I was to look at just generally what's
going on on Twitter these days it if I
was to walk down the street right now
somebody just everyday was waiting
outside my house and started screaming
at me and all sorts of things there's
legal recourse I could take right I can
file a what can I do if it's not a civil
suit and get an order of protection
against like people like I did a lot of
work back in the day when I was a young
lawyer for victims of domestic violence
and we were part of the beginning of the
orders of protection that got instituted
for them but it's not limited to the
domestic violence context it's anybody
who's stalking anybody who's harassing
anybody who's invading your privacy you
have an equitable right and a legal
right to bring legal action against them
and have the courts say I'm gonna stop
you from doing this and if you violate
this you're gonna be responsible for
legal fees you're gonna be responsible
for cost I can even put a statutory
amount on there and they often do
they'll say every time you violate this
it's a thousand dollars it's five
thousand ten thousand whatever is
necessary to deter those laws exist
already there so are those laws are
there any laws related to that that
exists in the digital space now again I
want to be very clean when we're doing
this because so for example all day long
trolls are jumping on me
go [ __ ] yourself well you know just the
word it's far worse than that usually
but I guess the worst kind of things all
day long same accounts I block on my
mutant they just make new accounts over
and over and over okay it's not the
worst thing in the world I'm still here
I'm alive it's okay right but doing it
in the digital realm I think people
would see that very differently than
stalking someone just outside of their
house or in the realm of reality it is
only to a certain degree the same laws
apply so it doesn't matter whether it's
the digital world or the physical world
the same stalking laws apply the same
harassing laws apply so somebody who
stalks can be sued somebody who stalks
they can even be charged with crimes
under particular cases so they can be
referred for criminal prosecution that's
happened to people that have done that
to Mike certain of it for example so the
so you can use civil remedies you can
request criminal remedies with criminal
referrals you can bring equitable
actions you can bring legal actions and
the courts are actually very sensitive
to it particularly like in California
where because of the problem of stalker
Otzi they expanded the kind of
protection either in the digital space
or the personal space and the US Supreme
Court is increasingly recognized that
these days those spaces are
indistinguishable so it's interesting to
me because as part of let's say the free
speech cruel online right now I'm very
president of a lot of this stuff because
it's like I want everyone to be able to
express themselves and yet I understand
we need certain super specific laws
libel laws slander laws harassment laws
and yet there's a certain irony where
it's like the free speech crew are the
ones that are gonna have to defend those
laws it's like a really weird place for
people like us to be and I think I agree
the way I think of it as I see it as an
unequal equation so what's happening is
you're seeing big media big powerful
forces people with big platforms be able
to defame little people that will be
able to run smear campaigns against
people it will be able to attack and
encourage stalking and harassment and
and online mobs that will and not be
held responsible and it's the little guy
that's still fighting for their free
speech and yet they're the ones the
little guy who's getting sued by big
institutional actors are backed by big
institutional players and they're being
sued for defamation they're being sued
for libel they're being sued for their
being the platformed and so we need to
do is equalize that playing field
because the First Amendment is also
about protecting everybody speech and
that means the little guy can't get
harassed in ways the big guy is immune
from and the big guy can't use powers
that the little guy doesn't have access
to so it needs to be equalized out so
true free speech means people who are
important in the independent press and
the freedom of press of the independent
press not be harassed not be not the
legal system not be used against them
disproportionately indiscriminately not
have the D platforming happening against
them disproportionately indiscriminately
and that's what's taking place and
that's what needs to equalize so true
free speech means we need to have some
equality of treatment between everybody
okay so now backing that to the platform
verse publisher part of this so they
they help get these law what statute did
you say to a section 230 section 230
okay so they they help get these laws
passed now they're treated as platforms
but it seems that they're acting often
more as publishers right
they now admit that so in other suits
that I've brought against Twitter they
said that they are a publisher and they
want all of the protections as a
publisher they want all the legal
privileges of a publisher because a
publisher has a wide range of special
protections particularly if it's has any
institutional form or backing so there's
certain libel laws that apply to
individuals differently than they apply
to corporations
the same is true of big media publishers
so they're now saying to courts so in
the Praeger suit against YouTube YouTube
in Google's defense is we're acting as a
censor we're acting as an editor we're
acting as a publisher and look at all
these privileges we have as a as a
publisher which a lot of people it was
one of the issues we raised was if
they're acting as a publisher they
shouldn't have the immunities of a
platform mm-hmm unfortunately the courts
have interpreted what Congress sent to
them in a political way this is often
the case with a lot of law a lot of laws
that interpret it through a political
framework and how they interpreted it as
oh the court as Congress doesn't want us
to allow big tech to be sued so we're
gonna give them all the protections as a
publisher and all the section 230
immunities as a platform so they have a
degree of protection as Senator Holly
described it a degree of immunity and
benefits that no publisher in the world
has that Congress is the one that
actually gave it to them as the courts
have construed it though some would
argue that's beyond what Congress
intended
right so Prager lost the initial lawsuit
correct are they and I know Dennis but I
actually don't know the answer it's are
they pursuing other legal measures that
you're still trying to go through the
appellate process but they're unlikely
to prevail under the current environment
because the current environment is such
that like the when I pursued Twitter I
brought unique novel theories I brought
breach of contract theories consumer
protection act theories because my
equitable theories because my view was
Twitter had lied to people to induce
their participation profited from that
participation sold that persons like a
someone like Charles Johnson would come
in and thirty thousand other people join
Twitter to follow Charles Johnson they
now have all of their private
information they get to aggregate that
information and then market eyes it and
monetize it and then they get to censor
and ban Charles Johnson forever from
Twitter because they don't like one
tweet he made well if my view is that's
really a breach of contract that's
really a breach of equitable duties and
obligations but the court saw oh
Congress is saying section 230 means I'm
not supposed to allow Twitter to ever be
sued for anything that's what's happened
and that's why Congress needs to fix
that side of the equation because
unfortunately the courts haven't stepped
up to do it themselves do you think
there's an interesting piece of this
that is just because of anonymous
accounts and I don't know what the legal
protections or non protections would be
around that
if you generally look at what's
happening online if you if we removed
anonymous accounts and by the way as a
free speech guy I'm not for that because
I understand off many times many times I
mean I see this with people that I meet
at live events they'll come up to me
after and they say you know I have an
anonymous account because I'm a
conservative and I don't you know so
it's not that there there's rules it's
not that they're flame claiming people
or whatever else it is but there's a
piece of me that thanks man if you just
removed anonymous accounts and and put
put aside the decent human part of it
for a second sure but actually 80 to 90%
of all of this nonsense would disappear
because you've got brave keyboard
warriors with no skin in the game that
are trying to sow havoc I don't know if
there's a legal piece of this somewhere
there's a legal way to do it so if
you're in operating on an anonymous
account and you're doing something
that's not protected by the First
Amendment like stalking like harassing
like a like invading someone's privacy
which is a broad tort that covers a wide
range of remedies including like in the
Covington Pei case they'll bring the
first case that establishes that doxxing
is in fact an invasion of privacy so you
can sue you can require the Twitter or
Google whoever did it Facebook identify
that individual and and consequently
that individual can be held legally
liable for their course of conduct so
people who think they can hide they can
do bad things behind anonymity you're
wrong they can do good things behind
anonymity in the First Amendment
encompasses that anonymity is often
critical to all kinds of free speech but
if what you're doing is always been
outside the scope of the First Amendment
like stalking like harassing like
intending to censor and shame people
based on lies and libels you can be held
individually liable and your anonymity
of your account will not protect you
from legal responsibility it's so
interesting because I'm hearing you on
all this and then there is this other
there's the absolutist part of me on
speech yeah that even though I know we
need these protections more than ever
there's just this little piece of me
that's like I don't want everything to
get caught up in legalese right and that
and I guess that ultimately is the
balance that guys like you have to deal
with every day absolutely it was the
pitch that we made to Senator Holly was
don't treat these as utilities and start
to regulate them I understand why people
are calling for that because what
they're seeing is monopoly power mm-hmm
the interesting thing is in the First
Amendment including in California
and it used to be the law and it still
is the law in some places which is if
you have the effect of a corporate
monopoly on the public square you were
then considered a state actor for First
Amendment purposes this was established
way back because you had company towns
who are like well how do we suppress
this union movement well why don't we
just own the whole town
we only sheriff we only copied on the
public square now we'll ban petitioning
now we'll ban circulating now we'll ban
organized so by that definition you you
would argue the social media companies
are absolutely okay that's called the
Pruneyard doctor here in the state of
California which applies to private
malls not malls can't ban you from
circulating certain things in the public
spaces of those private malls well is
there anymore monopolized public square
than big tech media then Twitter then
Facebook then YouTube then Google they
own they own 85 to 95 percent of the
public square and all corporations are
creations of the state and they get
certain protections for that because
they have a corporate charter they're
given certain immunities from individual
liability for participating in that
company
well I'm exchanged for that once they
get to the place where they monopolize
the public square those two things exist
both monopolies and the public square
which is usually over 75 80 percent
control of a market space when they have
that and when it's the public square I
think they should be held to the same
First Amendment standards as everyone
else because otherwise we create this
huge loophole in the First Amendment to
privatize control of the public square
so Eric Weinstein who I'm guessing
you're familiar with had a couple of
discussions with him about this and one
of the ideas that he's put forward and
my libertarian side doesn't really like
this but but I see some value in it is
that because we don't we don't have
public spaces online correct so it makes
everything so in effect everything's
private there's nothing public so the
government has nothing to do with
anything
but maybe this would be an actual good
use of the government if there were
platforms that were government platforms
that the only rule basically was you
can't break the laws of the United
States so that people could get their
information out there but you but if you
break the laws of the United States
you're in trouble then the private
companies could do whatever the hell
they wanted and we'd have no reason to
we'd have no ability to stop them but in
effect because everything is private
there's nothing public anymore right
exactly and so my view is that once you
become a monopoly and particularly you
become a monopoly
based on federal congressional immunity
then you have different obligations than
any other private actor so that's one
argument so one argument is if you
become if you become a man if you choose
to have a monopoly in the public square
space you're gonna have the same First
Amendment rules as any government actor
that's one option
another option is just to condition
their continued immunity on First
Amendment inclusion those are the
argument that I've made to the Twitter
lawyers in the Johnson case I was like
look you guys don't have to reinvent the
wheel like oh they said they were
worried about stalking and harassing and
it's like very simple just take all the
First Amendment rules that already exist
incorporate them within your Terms of
Service mhm and then you'll eliminate
90% of your concerns and questions and
you won't have to deal with a lot of the
nonsense right well yeah like right now
their rules would be considered void for
vagueness if they were saying because
you have rules that are subject to
individual women discretion and they're
intentionally written that way right so
I mean I did you catch any of Tim Poole
and Joe Rogan with Jack exactly yeah and
he detailed this instance after instance
after instance I mean the way they
decided to de platform Alex Jones was
highly subjective very interpretive and
I've seen far worse conduct only for
example the covington case you had a
prominent Hollywood figure show an image
of saying the ha saying the covington
kid should have to go through a shredder
yeah and be killed you had raised as
long calling from the be punched in the
face yeah nothing was done about that
and yet Alex Jones post something that's
just a funny video and they're like oh
my goodness we have to get rid of Alex
job okay so I want to spend a whole
bunch of time on covington because I
think actually that was the moment that
this shifted and and maybe at a legal
sense it crystallized in my mind a
little bit more that's actually when I
reached out to you sure because I saw
you just going for it going for it and I
thought okay this is a conversation we
have to have but let's let's talk about
Jones for a minute so Jones
so you've you've done some defense work
with Jones yes I'm representing Alex
Jones and Infowars
and now his outside general counsel on
all these legal matter so you represent
him across the board on all of these
things so I guess my first question is
what's it like when Alex Jones knocks on
your door or calls you up it was a very
animated guy very nice guy very open
very sincere what was fascinating is
from the get-go he was saying 90% of
what they're saying about me isn't isn't
the case he's like I would defend this
on free speech and free press grounds
anyway but what their acts
saying I said I didn't say I never
attacked these families I never went
after these family never told people to
go to the family's homes none of that
yeah this is that stuff specific he's
about the Sandy Hook exact the Sandy
Hook case and so that there they took a
Media Matters video and assumed that's
what I said and it wasn't really they
took most of that out of context and
didn't put in that I had corrected the
record a long time ago and so part of it
was you know very nice guy actually very
friendly guy very accessible guy even
more so than Snipes he gets mobbed when
he goes out in public with people
hunting selfies and that sort of thing
and he doesn't act like the Jaguar did
with the lady friendly so the runs at
you know nice small business enterprise
you know access TV to talk radio to
Internet and he's intended to be the
poster boy of their D platforming
campaigns they want to told the press as
this case really isn't about Alex Jones
it's about the ability of the
independent press to operate will law
fair be discriminately or disparately
used against ordinary individuals in the
same way that the platforming is
happening already in the big tech space
and so are we going to protect the
little guy or not and Alex Jones they
figured would be the convenient they
would sort of create a parody of them a
caricature of them that they could get
the public to believe make them make the
audience feel bad if they watch him mmm
they may feel guilty to be associated or
attacks with him and as soon as my
representation was announced in another
lawyer norm paddocks big old-school
civil rights lawyer in Connecticut I
think he still has a ponytail he's
old-school yeah he had friends and
family members that are connected to
what happened at Sandy Hook so he
immediately wanted to involved in the
case as soon as he was Huffington Post
writes a hit piece on they don't talk
about a civil rights legacy they don't
talk about any of that it's entire the
whole thing is intended to smear him and
it's sending a message that if you're a
lawyer and you dare defend Alex Jones
we're gonna try to destroy your
reputation in the public space and
that's exactly the problem that needs to
be fixed and remedied yeah so related to
Jones specifically I mean one of the
things that I thought was was most
incredible I forget the exact order of
it but basically within 48 hours all the
platforms took him down yes and it's
like okay is that is that that you guys
truly you're calling each other and
coordinating it or is it that you're all
sort of cowards you somebody breaks the
ice and now you're just followers and I
don't know that it matters either way
right Apollo doesn't matter either way
but what I thought was okay
it doesn't even matter what he has said
short of breaking an American law in my
opinion the real issue here is that if
he can't be on there then why is
Farrakhan on there I'm not even I'm not
making a comparison direct comparison
then why is Hamas on there we could do
it zillion other things you know the
disparity is obvious in evidence there
are people who've said far worse things
that just happen to have a different
ideological intellectual perspective
even if you took all the accusations
against them at face value and 90% of
them are not true the what and that's
your typical smear campaign the
conservative or the person on the right
or the person some on the independent
anti-war left will often be attacked and
smeared 90% of what said about them is
not true but even if it was true what
the other side has said is usually far
worse and far more egregious and far
more excessive and it's the obvious
disparate treatment they're using there
they're concentrated power to and and
including their lawfare power to
effectively wipe out the little guy so
that only the big guys voice is heard
and often it's about the audience
because that one job is still gonna talk
it's just can the audience here so it's
about their right to choose their right
to choose what news they want to look at
what views they want to have well how
they filter information obviously like
like I don't represent people that are
accused of racism or the rest people
their actual racist not everybody these
days everybody right well being accused
and being a traitor but people who are
really involved in some of generally
avoid representation of them the because
I just don't wanna be affiliate just
because that there's an old personal
issue but if you look at what those boys
said let those people debate because if
you watch Richard Spencer debate
somebody else ninety-nine percent of the
time the nice come reasonable person is
not going to say Richard Spencer is
right so always expose ideas to more
ideas more sunshine because let the
ideas get let trust the audience that's
really what they're all saying all what
big tech is doing what these big
lawsuits are doing against little guys
is intended to say we don't trust the
audience to make up their own mind we
don't trust the audience to make up
their own decisions we have to control
what you think we have to control what
you do because you might choose
something that we don't want you to do
if you actually have freedom of choice
freedom of thought freedom of expression
[Music]